is Europe
screwed you know what funny cuz I was
asked that question in Denmark about a
year ago and the video there's a minute
video of my response and apparently went
viral it's received millions and
millions of views very shocking are we
do what can be done about very shortly
yes you
are can you elaborate please yes
yes you're not doomed yet
but I
in all of world's history there has
never been a civilization that has so
opened its doors to another civilization
that is openly hostile to it so this is
unprecedented what's
happening your ancestors of
Europe and I describe it in my books
because I write about history fought
tooth and nail to prevent Islam from
entering and
conquering Europe because that was one
of the grand plans that went on for
Century after Century from the
East the Turks were trying to enter the
Constantinople they surrounded Vienna in
1683 and before that the Muslims I told
you went up into tours in France in 732
thousand years later this was an actual
goal and now Western Europe is saying oh
none of that matters it's all it was a
misunderstanding come on in but they
haven't changed that mental when I say
they you know that's obviously I'm
simplifying the mentality that I've
described is part of Islam it's an
Islamic concept so the Islamic State
you're told oh yeah they have nothing to
do with Islam they they've Twisted it no
they haven't they are a representation
of what Islam the kifs the sultanates
the Emirates that's how they operated
the heads of Islam the Grand imams and
the muftis said the same exact thing
okay so it's it that is what it
is again it's not my point to arguing oh
well this particular migrant wants to
conquer you maybe he doesn't maybe he's
looking for a good life I understand
that and that's what makes it
complicated but um to to just open your
borders completely to that demographic
which has within it not all of it but
within it that kernel of animosity for
Christians and so-called infidels and
the imperative to conquer the world in
the name of jihad for Allah which
they're the good guys keep in mind they
never see thems as the bad guys this is
one of the issues with all conflicts
they're not bad guys they're good guys
in their minds you're the bad guys
because you're infidels and they're
trying to bring the light of Islam to
you so that's another uh aspect of how
moral or the morality that they feel
they're the good guys okay in doing this
uh because look at you Denmark and
Europe you're all you're all dissipated
drunks and you know propagates and uh
you know there's no um no I'm I'm
sharing with you their arguments cuz I
read it hear it so they're bringing to
you goodness okay um but for but before
your ancestors because I guess they had
their own social order and their own
goodness and was called Christianity
were able to fight it but I guess in
this current void of sort of this
atheistic climate oh anything goes and
who's to say they're wrong maybe they're
right etc etc and now you have what's
happening um so it's a very
unprecedented experience a lot of people
talk about the Roman Empire this sort of
thing happened but it didn't and we can
get into that it was actually they were
still cognizant of trying to maintain
their own social cultural mores Rome and
it fell to the Goths and the Germanic
peoples I'm I'm just saying some people
use this analogy but in this case this
is completely you're doing not you but
it's Europe's doing okay you're bringing
a hostile Force that's openly hostile
and lo and behold when I look where
Muslims are I I see chaos and violence
and
criminality and rape and grooming in
England okay that's that's what always
happened under Islam okay so is there a
hope I think so um I hope so in time but
it's it's so bad that this even that it
even had to get to this point you know
it's such an abnegation and betrayal of
your own Heritage of these men and women
who fought and died to preserve your way
of life against an open hostile force
and and now they're being welcomed in
and you know oh what why not it's okay
so I guess uh so it's a matter of time
so where's the Hope excuse me so where's
the hope you said there there is the
hope is to wake
up wake up and see what reality and what
I'm talking about and understand the
history and the doctrine of Islam and
what Islam is all about Islam is
unequivocally hostile to the non-muslim
if you ever read the Quran you don't
even read the Quran I mean just anything
all I have to do is sit and listen to
your average Friday sermon and it's just
violence and killing and subjugating
okay so why would you if you are a
peaceloving neutral people who don't
want to who believe in religious freedom
and equality why would you want people
who believe the exact opposite living
amongst you especially after the
experiment has gone so ay and G and
wrong and you've seen with your own eyes
how bad it is I don't know which is the
worst country but I heard a lot recently
about Sweden being a complete shambles
okay and they have the most Muslims so
surely there's a correlation between a
country that's about to collapse and the
number of Muslims there okay but you
have to be able to be honest with with
yourselves and make that connection and
even more difficult uh act according to
it even though it may make you look like
the bad guys Europe basically is like
it's this you know a place that just
created its own problem you know you
created your own headache it's going to
get worse for it gets better this never
had to be like that and all you have to
do is look at those countries who didn't
allow Muslim migration hungry for
example maybe Poland a little bit yeah
and it's kind of like they don't have
these problems do they people can walk
on the streets women aren't being raped
left and right so it wasn't that hard
you just put up a fence right yeah so
this is like all self-induced problems